I think I'm going to start.
Um,
so this is really the beginning
of the finance part of the course.
So far we've reviewed general equilibrium,
which I said Fisher invented or
reinvented in order to do finance.
And as you remember, the, the, the,
the main conclusions from general
equilibrium are first that uh,
the market functioning by itself
without interference from the outside.
In other words,
the situation of Laissez faire leads
to allocations that are parade Oh,
efficient.
So they're in some sense good for
the economy and good for the society.
They don't maximize total welfare.
That's not even a well defined
thing as we saw last time.
Because how can you measure, how can
you add one person's utility to another?
It doesn't even make sense.
So economists at first were wrong to
think of that as the criterion for good
allocations.
But there's another better
definition of efficiency.
That parade oh invented
called Credo efficiency.
And the free market achieves pray to
efficiency at least if there are no
externalities and there's no monopoly.
So that lesson number one was taken
to mean that the government shouldn't,
shouldn't interfere in the free market,
especially shouldn't interfere
in financial markets.
And that's something we're
going to come to examine.
The second lesson we found was that the
price is determined by marginal utility.
So if you, it's not determined
by total utility. So, uh,
it may be that water is much more valuable
than diamonds because it does a lot
more good for everybody and for the
world as a whole than diamonds do.
But the last drop of water, really, most
people have as much water as they need.
The last drop of water's
not doing that much,
whereas the last diamond is a rare
thing and not many people have them.
So the last drop of water is worth less
than the last equal weight of diamonds.
And therefore water's much
cheaper than diamonds,
even though waters much more
valuable as a whole than diamonds.
The price of things depend on
their marginal utility. Uh,
so you, you, uh,
a third implication of what we did is
that there's no such thing as the just
price. It depends on what people's
utilities are and how much they like it.
It depends on how much
of the good there is.
That's why diamonds are priced less
than water. And it depends on who,
how wealthy people are.
If you chance for money from people who
don't like apples compared to tomatoes
to people who like apples
a lot compared to tomatoes,
the price and the free market is going
to reflect more of the latter class of
people than the former because
they've got the money to spend.
And so the price of apples is going to
go up relative to the price of tomatoes.
So those are the three basic lessons
of general equilibrium, which we,
the first one about laissez faire
has a huge implication for what we,
whether there should be regulation, but
the second pair of implications, uh,
you know,
what determines the price
and price changes as you
redistribute wealth and so on.
And no just price.
That set of ideas you'll see is also
going to be very important for finance.
So those lessons seem clear.
Some of those lessons were understood
already by Aristotle, as we said,
till the ancients understood
supply and demand,
at least a little bit
of supply and demand.
And yet as soon as they moved from
apples and oranges to finance,
they all got hopelessly confused.
So Aristotle said,
interest is unnatural.
I could go through a lot of people
in what they said, but I'm gonna,
I'm gonna just leave it at a few,
a few quotations.
The Bible says interest
is terrible. Judaism, um,
frowns on interest.
Christianity frowns on his interest.
Islam frowns on interest.
All the great religions of the world
crystallizing obviously some of the most
important thing.
You have the time frowns on interest.
So just to remind you
of a few. Um, so what,
what, what, why do they frown on interest?
Well, the idea is that, you know,
you do nothing.
The lender does nothing and he gets
Mac more than he lent to begin with.
He's making a profit without having
exerted any effort whatsoever. So,
so a named Middleton said, in trade,
both parties are expected to gain,
whereas in lending it usury
only the user could profit.
So, um, you know, in
Deuteronomy, in the Bible,
so this is the Jewish Bible. It
says, thou shalt not land unusually.
That just means interest. That'll show
up much lend on usury to thy brother,
usually of money,
usually evict duals,
usually of anything that has lent
upon usury. That's all terrible.
Of course, unto a foreigner, thou mayest
lend upon usury. But unto a brother,
thou shalt not lend upon usury.
Okay?
So the Jews could lend to Christians,
but not to each other.
So the Christian Church outlawed usury,
called it a mortal sin.
Luther, for example, says for who? So
Lens that he wants it back better or more.
That is open and damnable Aaker, those
who do that are all daylight, robbers,
thieves, and occurs. Those are
little Jewish arts and tricks.
So, um, there was this
antipathy towards usury.
And because Jewish money lenders were
able to lend to Christians, and there,
there was a,
an antipathy to Jewish money lenders,
which are going to come to
when we talk about Shakespeare.
So Muslims also forbid, uh,
lending. In fact, even today,
it's illegal to charge
interest in Islamic law.
So in my hedge fund we
tried to raise money. Uh,
I mean there's lots of money in the
Middle East so we try and, and most of it,
by the way,
10 years ago was invent almost all
Middle Eastern money was invested in US
government bonds in us stocks, nothing
else, like in mortgages for instance.
So we,
I went to a Saudi Arabia and I meant
a bunch of brothers of the king,
you know,
the Elvis brothers of kings.
And I suggest that they invest in our
hedge fund and they actually became sort
of interested. And so we had to write up
a complicated contract. I mean, you know,
a mortgage pays interest.
So if you invest in the hedge in the
hedge fund and the mortgages paying
interest, it looks like they're getting
interest. And so that wasn't going to do.
So we had to write a
very elaborate contract,
which disguise the fact that interest
was being paid and it had to be overseen
and a blessed according to Sharia law,
by a holy person who was going to
verify that there was no interest.
Now he charged a fee,
which was a percent a year,
which looked an awful lot
like interest. But anyway, so,
so the point is all these religions have
banished interest despite the fact that
they themselves were involved in
interest in lending and borrowing.
And so all of it, you know, you just,
the world can't function really without
lending and borrowing and the charging
of interest.
But so I don't mean to so,
so these religions that for baited at
the same time knew that it was going on
and uh, allowed it to go on and
sometimes participate in it.
But the point I'm trying to make
is that there was vast confusion.
And even today there's confusion because
still today the Jewish law doesn't
allow for interest between Jews and it's,
there's this charade that goes on there
just like there is and in Islamic law
and just like there is a still
frowned upon by the Christian Church.
So, um, it's a hard subject to
understand. And why is that?
Why is it that it's so confusing
and how should we understand it?
Well Fisher cut through all
of this extremely simply.
And the way he did it was to,
he said,
let's just think mathematically then
we won't get so tied up in all these
religious complexities. Just let's do
something mathematical and concrete.
So suppose that we consider a problem,
which is the one I'm going to
work with the rest of the class.
Maybe it'd better be over here.
So let's say that there are two agents,
um, uh, and to goods.
So the two goods now or x one and x two.
So Fisher's first insight is that let's
think of x one and x two is apples,
but apples today and Apple's next year,
Fisher said,
although they're both
apples exactly alike,
there's no difference
between these apples.
The apples this year are different
goods from the apples next year.
So let's move away from
apples and tomatoes to apples
this year and Apple's next
year. So not going to call
them goods x and y anymore.
I'm going to subscript them by time.
So x,
these are both ex cause it's
the same. Good. But they're,
they're different goods because they
occur at different time periods.
So Fisher said we can incorporate time,
uh, simply by having different goods.
So of course people he said are
going to have some utility, uh,
of consuming today versus
consuming tomorrow.
And let's say this utility is
log x one plus half log x two.
Okay. For Mr a. So I'm going
to come back to this, uh,
in half an hour [inaudible] point and
explain why Fisher thought that this half
made sense. You see this agent
a thinks a lot more likes,
good one,
a lot more than good too.
So official would say that's because agent
a is impatient and apple is an apple.
But if you get it now,
it's worth more to you.
It gives you a higher utility
than getting an apple next year.
This is a law of human nature.
He claimed,
which I'm going to come back to later
and it, and uh, that's why people, uh,
when you write down the utility function,
there's a discount factor,
which we're going to
add a discount factor,
which discounts reduces the utility
you get from future consumption.
So let's say you B of x one
and x two is equal to a log x
plus log x too.
So B is more patient then a is B
actually doesn't discount the future.
A does discount the future.
So a is impatient,
relatively impatient and be as patient.
Okay, so then let's make it,
they haven't Dauman so e a,
let's say the endowment
is one zero and um,
say it's one,
one and an e B.
Let's make that a one zero.
Okay.
But now Fisher wants to talk about finance
and he wants to talk about stocks and
bonds and interest and all kinds of
things. So he says, okay, you know,
we've talked about goods with no problem.
We can talk about goods today
and next year with no problem.
Let's talk about stocks. What is a
stock? Let's say there two stocks. Okay.
Stock Alpha and Stock Beta.
So Fisher says,
I mean w w what are stocks?
I mean there are pieces of
paper that you're trading,
but they give you ownership of
something like a factory or a company or
something. And what's good,
what good is the company? Well,
the good of the companies that
it's going to produce something.
So let's say that the stock is going
to produce something in the future.
So we'll call the production of the stock.
So what is it?
What is the future? It's
just X. There's only one.
They're only apples in the future.
So let's say d
two is one and d Beta two
equals two.
Okay. So Fisher says, uh, you know,
you can tell a lot of stories about
what the stock does and what, you know,
what it's method of
production is and you know,
what kind of managers that has and a
lot of stuff like that. But in the end,
people care about the stock because the
stock is going to produce something and
the value of the stock is going
to come from what it produces.
So d Alpha two is what people expect
the output of the stock to be next year,
which is the last year we're
worrying about and debated to,
which is two is what people expect
the stock to produce next year.
And we're going to assume that,
uh, perfect foresight here.
So Fisher says, well, you know, in general
people's expectations might be wrong,
but let's start off with the case.
When people anticipate something,
surely they're looking
ahead to the future.
When deciding whether to buy the stock,
we've got to assume something
about what they think.
Let's suppose they actually get it right
and they know what the price of the
stock is next period. Okay. So what's
going to, uh, what's going to happen?
Um,
well we can define an economy and
presumably the interest rate and the stock
prices and all of that are going to come
out. Now I should mention, by the way,
I forgot to say this, uh, but as I
write this down, I suddenly realize,
I forgot to mention it.
You know,
there are other theories of interest to
another famous one was Marx's theory of
interest. So, uh, this is to be
contrasted with Fisher marks.
What did Marx say? So in my
youth, when I was your age,
it was very fashionable to be a
Marxist. Um, so every, all of you know,
you could almost, anyway,
you had to study Marxism.
Basically if you wanted to talk to women,
you had to know about marks. So anyhow,
I dutifully went off and red marks.
And so what's the idea of marks?
The idea was that uh,
he imagined a,
an agricultural economy where you plant
stuff today and then the output comes
out tomorrow. He put corn in, in,
in today. Corn comes out tomorrow.
So it doesn't require much effort to plant
the corn. It requires a lot of effort.
You have to buy the corn. So the
capitalists would, would buy the corn,
but planning it didn't require much
effort. However, harvesting it, you know,
picking the cotton, you know,
picking the chocolate, um, you know,
picking all that stuff
takes a lot of effort.
So in the end you'd get a lot of output.
Now when you pick the output,
you'd have to pay workers in order to,
to pick the output.
So Mark's imagine that there was a wage
that was arrived at by the struggle
between,
uh,
struggle class struggle between the
capitalist and the workers over the
subsistence wage.
So the subsistence wage was something
that resulted subsistence wage resulted
from this huge class struggle and um,
you know,
over time maybe it would rise as,
as workers got stronger,
but it was still always quite low and
the subsistence wage was what the workers
would get and what's leftover,
which was the surplus. Okay.
What was the output being more than what
was put in was the surplus part of the
surplus would go to the subsistence wage,
the rest would go to profit.
And so if you look in how
much was put in to begin with,
you get all the output back out,
the same amount of corn
you put in plus some extra,
you have to give it to the workers
and extra you give to uh, the, the,
the capitalist gets back at his,
at his profit.
The fact that the capitalist has done no
work at all. He's just bought the corn,
let someone else plant it, let someone
else harvested, paid all those guys,
virtually nothing at the
beginning and a lot at the end,
he's gotten profit for doing nothing,
just like when you lend money.
And so this profit,
so the profit divided
by the initial outlay,
that's,
that was the rate of interest.
And so, uh, Mark's Ed that a capitalist,
he could put his money in his bank or
he could run this farm and make profit
this way.
So the money interest in the bank would
have to turn out to be the same as this
rate of profit. Otherwise he put all the
money in the bank. And if it was smaller,
he wouldn't,
you know,
the banks would have to give higher
interest in order to attract depositors.
So the capitalist profit rate of interest
was determined by the rate of profit
and the rate of profit was determined by
the struggle between capital and labor.
Okay. So we've got these religious
figures and great philosopher saying,
interest is terrible. We've got this
great philosopher, economist thing.
It's the result of a class struggle.
And now we've got Fischer actually
marks was pretty mathematical.
But now we've got Fisher turning it
into a simple math problem and saying,
let's reason out the math problem and
we'll have the answer to these questions
and it'll turn out to be quite different
for one. All of these guys are saying,
so his, so here's his economy
that I just described,
the Fisher example,
not literally an example he gave,
but similar to one he gave. So he said,
all right, what happens in this economy?
Let's just be very common sensical.
What we need to find out now is,
is financial like Librium.
So financial equilibrium is much more
complicated seeming than we had before
because we care about the prices. So
on, I'm going to use Q for prices.
So these are going to be
Iq for contemporary prices.
Queue contemporary. So the price you
pay today to get the apple today,
Q two is the price you pay
next year to get the apple.
Next year they're contemporary
prices. Okay. And then, but we,
we've got a more I and of course people
are going to decide what they want to do.
X a one what they're going
to end up consuming x eight,
two x B one x v two,
but now we've got a
more complicated world,
their stocks to be traded.
So,
and there's the price of stocks.
So p Pi Alpha,
I'm running out of letters.
I'm going to switch to a Greek one.
This is the price of stock.
Yay.
Stock Alpha
and Pi Beta is the price of stock Beta.
Okay.
And then we have to know what,
what are people going to,
how many shares are they going to
hold? Well, it's going to be Feta, uh,
a is going to hold certain
number of shares, Alpha and
a is going to hold a certain number of
shares of stock Beta and B's going to
hold a certain number of shares of Alpha
and a certain number of shares of Beta.
So we want to solve for all of that.
Now I should have said at the beginning
if these are trees producing apples,
there was an initial stock
of,
of uh,
people owned a certain number of trees,
let's say Theta Alpha a.
So this is the original ownership,
regional ownership
of Alpha. Okay, let's just say
that. I'll make up some number of,
might as well use the same number I
thought of before. Let's say that right?
And let's say Feta Be Alpha is zero.
And let's say Feta bar a Aveda is a half
and fade up Barbie of Beta is a half.
Okay, so what we've begun, so this is,
so the original economy
is more complicated than
before because we've added
stocks, we characterize
the stock, we said okay,
your stock is a very complicated thing.
Accompanies very complicated,
depends on managers and processes.
And you know,
there's all kinds of stuff you think
about when you think about a stock.
But really at heart,
all people are trying to do is forecast
what are they going to produce.
And so we're going to make it
simple mathematically and say,
let's say we know what they're
going to produce next period.
And then people be getting,
so let's say it's a tree,
everybody knows the Alpha
trees producing one apple,
the Beta trees producing two,
two apples.
Alpha happens to own the only
alpha tree and Beta and a and B.
A owns the Alpha tree,
excuse me,
and a and B own half
each of the Beta tree.
Okay,
so that's the original economy and the
equilibrium is going to be how are they
going to, what are the prices going
to turn out to be of x one and x two,
what are the prices of the
tree's going to turn out to be?
How much will people consume
and how money shares. I mean,
because Alpha a began
with all of the tree.
Maybe he'll sell his shares of tree and
ended up with not having a tree in the
end.
So we have to see where they began,
the stock ownership to begin
with and where they end up.
So that's what we have to solve.
All of that.
And it looks way more complicated than
before and so complicated that you can
see why people might have gotten confused,
but agreeing to Fisher,
it's going to turn out to be a very simple
problem in the end once we look at it
the right way.
So are there any questions about what
the economy is and what are the variables
that we're trying to explain?
Yeah, I can't remember.
That says over a Beta Alpha
original ownership of stock Alpha and
this is original ownership by B of Stock
Alpha.
This is original ownership by a of stock
Beta and this is the original ownership
by B of stock Beta original
ownership of Alpha.
Thanks. Yep. Yes. Let me get
my note. These contributing
d is the dividend. That's the output
that we can all, okay, thank you.
I should just write this down.
This is
the anticipated dividend,
which is the output since isn't,
that's the end of the world of stock Alpha
in period two
and
Bake d Beta of two is the anticipated
dividend of stock Beta in period two.
So it's one apple.
We're getting out of the Alpha treat two
apples out of the Beta tree and we're
right. That's what the trees good for.
We could look at how beautiful it is.
We could, we could talk about how much
the owners actually watering the tree.
We can talk about a lot of
complicated stuff, but in the end,
all we care about is how many
apples we expect to get out of it.
All the eyes of stuff goes into helping
us think about how many apples we're
going to get out of it and the end.
So we cut to the bottom line.
What are the apples we expect
to get out of the tree?
One from the apple tree
to from the Beta tree.
There was someone else had their hand up.
Okay.
Any other questions about the setup?
Okay,
so we're returning to first
principles here. Very simple
example. You know, the, uh,
when there's ever a big confusion
about something important,
it's always good to go
to first principles.
There was a chess player when
I was young. They, Mikhail Tal,
who is a world champion for a little
while and he said that every two or three
years he'd go back and read his original,
you know,
introductory textbooks on chess.
Um,
so we're going back to
the first principles.
How would you define equilibrium here
for a financial equilibrium? Well,
the first thing, you know,
it's just common sense.
What are people doing at time one?
They're going to, what can they do?
They can spend money. So let's say,
so I'm going to look at the budget set
for agent I,
you know,
and I can be a or B, so I don't
have to write it twice. Okay.
So he's going to say to himself,
let's say a, is he and be as she,
he's gonna say, okay, I is he,
he's going to say to himself, uh,
let's say I can, um, I will say,
how much does it cost me to buy goods?
Well,
the cost of apples is Q1 times.
Excellent.
That's how many apples
I might end up with.
Now how much does it
cost me to buy shares?
It's going to be Pi Alpha Times.
How many shares I ended up
with Theta Alpha plus Pi Beta
trying to stay debater.
Hey,
so I'm buying goods,
I'm buying Alpha shares and I'm buying
Beta shares and this is how much I have
to spend to get the
holdings I want of each.
Now where did I get the money to do that?
I got the money to do that because I
started with my endowment, you know,
of goods,
which was e one which in this case for
a was one unit for B was also one unit.
And then I also had shares to
begin with of these stocks.
So I had feta bar,
Alpha plus Pi,
Beta Theta Barbido that's,
that's in period one.
That's what I had to do.
I wanted to buy apples shares and I
had shares to sell an apples to sell.
So that's uh,
that's what I did.
So of course if x one is bigger than
the number of apples I started with,
that means I has bought apples cause he
ends up with more than he started with.
So on net he must've been buying apples.
If Theta Alpha is more than of Alpha,
alphabet means that Alpha
bought shares of stock.
Alpha Theta Alpha is less
than fate of our alpha.
It means Alpha sold shares of stock Alpha.
Okay,
all right.
Now in the second period,
what happens when the second period
we have Q two times x two now nobody,
the shares are going to be worthless in
period two so no one's going to buy them.
Why are the sheriff's worthless? Remember
that when you buy a share of stock you,
the dividend comes later.
You don't get the dividend immediately.
So someone buying stock in period two
it's too late to get the dividends.
It's already gone to the owner who
bought the shares and period one.
So the, the buyer of a stock
gets the dividend, you know,
for a month or something.
So next period's dividend is still
going to go to the buyer in period one.
That's why it's valuable to buy shares
in period one cause you get next year's
apple. Okay? So by next
period you can buy the tree,
but the world's coming to an end.
The tree's not going to do any good.
It doesn't produce any more apples.
So nobody's going to bother buying shares.
I don't have to bother with
them. The prices or zero. Okay.
And so what income do people
have in period two? Well,
name got the contemporaneous price times,
you know,
the apples that somehow they find on
the ground that they're, you know,
or that their parents are going
to leave them when they get old.
So that's their endowment of apples.
But what else do they have?
They've got more apples than that.
What else do they have?
The dividends. Okay. And so
what are the dividends? Well,
you bought Theta Alpha to begin with,
so that's d alpha too. So
if you bought, you know,
the whole tree, then you've got all
the dividends and similarly with them,
Meda,
meda,
the out the Beta to [inaudible].
Okay, so that's it. So the budget's set
is a little more complicated. It's a,
so that's the budget.
So,
hey, so let's got to equality's
instead of one. A quality is already,
things look a little more complicated now.
So an equilibrium is going to happen.
The Bay that uh,
I chooses
x,
I want x to Seda,
uh, Alpha. You know, I could
write a seda I Alfa Feta,
I beda
it's all the choices he has.
Uh,
to maximize,
ew,
I subject to this budget set.
Okay, so a is going to pick,
you know, what shares to hold,
how much to to consume today.
And then of course looking forward is
going to be able to figure out what he's
going to end up consuming
tomorrow. All right, so
and now in equilibrium we have to have
that x a one plus x B one has to equal e
a one plus e a e B one.
Okay. And x a two. And then,
and then we'll do the shares theta.
A Alpha plus theta be
alpha has equal fader bar,
Alpha plus theta bar. The Alpha, right.
The stock market has to clear and theta
a Beta plus theta B Beta as an equal say
to Barb a fade.
Huh?
Let's say the bar be bait.
Hazel in period one,
the demand for apples has to equal
the supply of all the agents.
Okay. But now what's the last
equation? This is a little trickier.
What's the last step?
Equation x.
A two plus x.
B two equals e Ey two plus e be too.
Is that it?
No,
there's something else.
So though the dip,
the apples are right.
The total consumption of apples is going
to be the apples that they have on the
ground, but also the ones that were
picked off the trees. So these dividends,
so it's going to be the total dividends,
switcher Theta Bar,
a Alpha plus Beta bar B
Alpha Times that tree,
the Alpha two plus fade up bar a Beta
plus Theta Bar B Beta Times d beta.
Okay, so, so just to say it in words,
it's exactly what we had before except
we have to take into account in addition
to the goods market clearing,
we have to take into account that the
stock market has to clear and in the end,
demand for goods has to equal the supply
that people had in their endowments,
but also what the companies are producing.
These companies are producing output,
you know,
apples.
And so that's part of what's the
consumption is going to be in the economy.
Okay. Are you with me here as a
good time for questions? Maybe?
Yes.
Could you just explain again
why you don't pick stocks?
Okay.
So in period two you might wonder Pi Alpha
is the price of a stock at period one
stock Alpha in period one Pi Beta is the
price of the stock Beta in period one.
How come I didn't write down list price
of the stocks and period two and keep
track of what they're holding in period
two and the reason is that when you buy
a stock, you're buying it not for the
dividends at the same moment in time,
you don't get those dividends. The guy
who already had it gets those dividends.
When you buy the stock, you're buying
it for the future dividends you can get.
And I have assumed the world's going
to end after two periods cause nobody's
utility, you know, cares
about period three.
So if you buy the stock in period two
it's too late for you to get anything.
There are no dividends because peer,
you could only get them in period three
and there won't be any dividends in
period three. And if there were,
you wouldn't care about them anyway,
so the stock is worthless to you.
So the price of the stock in period
two of both stocks is going to be zero.
So there's no point in putting down
what people are buying of the stocks are
selling or anything. It's just not worth
anything. But in general, you're right.
And we're going to be more complicated,
uh,
later when you look at your income from
having bought the stocks you'll have as
your income, the dividends from the
stocks plus the resale value of the stock,
because you could sell
the stock next period.
But I just know the resale value is going
to be zero because you're in the last
period of the economy.
Okay.
And I just want to keep it
very simple this first time.
So you, it, you could, yeah.
So we'll see, you know, step by step,
you'll be able to keep very
complicated things in your head,
but not right the first. Yeah.
So any other questions? Yes.
Why are there,
you mean why do people,
um,
having endowments today and next year
because you could think of the endowment
for example as here we've got apples
but usually the endowment is your labor.
So you can work this year.
What have you most important endowment
is your energy and your labor.
So you've got it this year. Next year
if you're still alive you're going to,
that's new labor that you have.
It's a different good.
So it's a second endowment that you have.
So you know,
I don't want to get caught up in labor
and all that and get involved with marks
again.
So I'm just going to talk about apples.
Do you have an endowment of apples
when you're young and next year somehow
you're going to have more apples.
So you could think of the,
you might have thought that
the only apples next year
coming from what the firms
are producing.
But you know,
I've allowed for the possibility
that people have apples too,
just like their labor next
year. Okay. Other questions?
Yeah, we didn't have to
be fine. He to a youtube,
the first few then downs or are they,
is that sort of implied?
Well, this is a, this is e h I
should written this more carefully.
Maybe e and e eight is that,
and this is e B one and B two is that,
okay?
So as he was suggesting back there,
I have assumed for person B that you know,
he's got an apple now somehow
the world, you know, we,
we aren't modeling what happened to get
us here. The guy got an apple today.
They both have an apple today.
Somehow A's also going to have another
apple tomorrow. That a, you know,
he's going to find under his doorstep
somehow that isn't being produced by the
tree. And maybe you can think of it as
Labor that he's gonna have next period.
Okay.
All right. So that's it. Fisher says,
as soon as you write down the economy,
mathematically,
all sorts of things are
going to occur to you,
which if you're talking in words
about justice and injustice,
you know you're going to
be lost. So what, what,
what can we get right away out of this?
Uh,
Well,
the first thing is how
would we define inflation?
What is inflation?
What's inflation? And this economy,
assuming we've got the equilibrium,
which we're going to get soon,
we're going to calculate it,
but right now we don't know
what the numbers, you know,
we've got a bunch of equations and stuff.
We don't know what x a one in Q one
and Q two are going to turn out to be,
but we're gonna find out very soon.
But before we find out,
assuming we've gotten those, what
will inflation B, what is inflation?
Yup.
Well,
we're talking about inflation.
When you talk about the
consumer price index inflation,
what are they talking about?
Yup.
Okay. So inflation is just
Q two over Q one, right?
So that's the price of apples today.
It's the price of apples next year.
If the price of apples next year is bigger
than this year, we've got inflation.
If it's lower, we've got deflation.
Okay, so already the model,
you're talking about
inflation. Okay, what else?
What's the next most obvious?
Uh,
okay.
Okay,
well I think I'm going to skip a bunch
of stuff and get now to the key idea.
He idea is arbitrage.
Okay. So Fisher says people have,
you know, they have four sites.
They're anticipating what the
dividends are going to be.
They, they, they, they can,
you know, they that, you know,
you can talk about how beautiful the
tree is and how much you like the owners
and how much they're
watering it and all kinds of,
what do they have a good plan
for irrigation and you know,
whether they did well in college
and stuff like that. But in the end,
all you care about the trees is what,
how many apples they're going to produce.
So knowing that, can we say something
about Pi Alpha versus Pi Nedo
enact delivery,
what's going to have to happen?
They're going to be some connection.
And what's the connection going to be?
You've got two trees.
Yeah.
Right. So Pi Alpha is going
to be Pi Beta at times d.
Um, uh, let's see. Pi Out. Okay.
So Alpha will be better as long as the,
okay.
Oh, I haven't got, I've got that in the
right order. If, and so in this case,
Pi Alpha is going to equal a half Pi
Beta because Alpha is producing half the
dividend,
the Betas producing.
So obviously it's going to turn out
to have half the price that that's the
fundamental principle. Okay. We're
doing it in the most trivial case,
but so most fundamental
principle of finance that he's,
we've got two assets and one of them,
they're basically the same up to scale.
Then their prices have to
be the same up to scale.
Who's going to bother to buy alpha if it
costs three times, if it costs, you know,
the same amount as Beta when
it only produces half as much.
Okay. Yes. Same thing. Same thing.
Well it is something like that, but
that's a word that we haven't defined yet.
So we're going to define it in the next
class. So it's something like that. Yup.
Any other,
okay,
so that is a very simple thing now.
So polls I added.
Suppose I added, okay,
so here's, here's a a
suppose I added.
Suppose after finding the equilibrium,
I added a third asset
acid that paid
oh $1
period.
Two next year.
Okay, now it would have a price.
I've added a third acid gamma.
Then what? So Pi Gamma, we'd have to
solve for the equilibrium pie gamma,
and is there some word that I could use?
How could I,
so gamma is an asset that
pays a dollar in period two.
It's a bond promising
a dollar in period two.
The price of the bond
would then have to be what?
One over one plus I where I is
called the nominal interest rate.
So we've got inflation is occurring
in the model. If I added a bond,
which I didn't bother to do because
it's just yet another thing I'd have to
write down, I could've had a
third acid, which pays a dollar.
So the others are paying off in an apples.
This one's paying a dollar and
it's priced today. You know,
if you pay 80 cents today, it's like
saying I'm paying 80 cents today,
I'm getting a whole dollar tomorrow.
So
it's like a 25% rate of interest.
Okay.
Because another way of saying it
is that I put in Pike, you know,
so one over Pi Gamma's one plus I,
I put only Pi Gammon today.
I get one out tomorrow. So I've gotten
back not only the Pi Gam I put in,
but something extra. That's one plus
the interest rate. Okay? So the,
the this world is going to have an
interest rate in and he's going to have
inflation in it with me so far. All right.
So now Fisher makes his most important.
Okay.
So let me add one more thing. I could
come back to this. So I said that
I said that,
um,
okay.
I said that if you take Feta
Alpha less than fader Bar Alpha,
it means you're selling the stock.
So I'm going to allow people to go even
further Theta Alpha less than zero.
Okay?
So let me just write that again.
Theta Alpha less than fader
Bar Alpha means means,
uh,
selling
Alpha Feta Alpha
less than zero is doing a
lot more than selling you.
You don't have it to begin with. So how
can you, what are you selling? Well,
the mathematics is telling you that
over here they'd Alpha's going to be
negative. You've got your, instead
of getting extra dividends,
you're going to be giving up dividends
because it's going to reduce your supply
of money. So Theta Alpha, less
than zero is called selling short.
Know
which one I've lost.
That'd be bad.
Okay, so you're, you're, uh, if you can
still hear me, you're selling short.
This means
AC.
You're selling something you don't even,
you don't even have,
or it's also called making selling.
It's also called making a promise
without collateral.
Okay?
So I'm going to for now allow for that.
So we're not taking into account
that anybody's defaulted.
If you take Feta Alpha negative,
it means your income in the future is
going to be reduced because you're going
to have to deliver the dividend because
you're going to have negative dividends,
which means effectively you take out of
your endowment those dividends and hand
them over. So it's so it's as if
you always keep your promises.
So this model, so far, the
official model assumes no default,
no collateral. We're not worrying
about any of that stuff. Okay?
And of course that's going
to be a critical thing. So,
okay,
you see some things happen that we never
happen had happened before. In the past,
you traded money for a football ticket,
you gave up something you wanted,
you got something, uh, that you also
wanted. It was a trade of value for value.
Everybody agreed the two things
you traded are equally valuable.
If you take Feta Alpha negative by
taking Theta Alpha negative, hey,
that becomes a negative number here.
So it allows you to spend more,
you can buy more goods by taking
Feta Alpha negative, that's negative.
That means this can be more positive
and still satisfy this constraint.
So by selling a stock short,
you're,
you're promising to do
something in the future,
you get more money now
you can eat more now.
And then of course you have to consume
less than the future cause you have to
pay back your promise. So you're
exchanging something valuable. You're you,
you know you're getting money. Something
valuable in exchange for a promise,
which is worth nothing until the future.
When you deliver on your promise,
when you buy the stock,
you know you're buying part of the tree,
but the trees doing nothing for you.
Now you're doing it because it's
going to be valuable. Next period,
you're actually not
physically owning the tree.
You're owning a piece of paper that gives
you a right to have the dividends of
the tree.
So you're getting something that's only
good because it's a promise you think
has been kept. Okay, so so far we're
going for the next few lectures.
We're going to ignore the fact that
people get very nervous when they give
something up that's valuable in exchange
for something. That was just a promise.
What? Okay, so a critical
thing has happened here.
So we've kept the same mathematics,
except we've surreptitiously added
this huge assumption. Now Fisher said,
having done that,
what can you realize?
This is the most important insight. He
said, this model, it looks so complicated.
It looks like now we have
vastly more equations,
no wonder marks and all those religious
zealots. We're getting confused,
you know,
uh,
we can simplify it all and be back to
where we were before and yet talk about
finance.
So Fisher introduced the
idea of present value prices.
Okay? So he said, look, when you buy
a stock, what are you really doing?
This is the principle of arbitrage.
She says, when you buy a stock,
you're saying to yourself,
I'm giving up money today.
Now money today is consumption.
Because I would have used that
money if I didn't buy stocks,
I would've bought apples today and
eating them. So when I buy a stock,
I'm giving up apples.
Today I'm getting the stock,
which is then paying me dividends
tomorrow, which whatever they are,
I'm selling off. You know, I'm,
I'm getting a profit out of the
stock tomorrow and an Emmet,
I'm ending up with Apple's tomorrow.
Maybe I'm just eating the
dividends straight off the
tree. So when I buy a stock,
I'm really giving up apples today
and getting apples tomorrow.
And no matter how I do it,
whether it's through stock Alpha or
through stock Beta or through a nominal
bond,
it's got to be the case that all three
ways or all 50 other ways you could
imagine doing it half to
give me the same trade off.
This is your yield.
You were talking about the same trade off.
The amount of apples I effectively give
up today in order to get apples tomorrow
is going to be the same. No matter which
way I do it. If it weren't the same,
if, if Alpha is price was more than a
half of Betas, nobody would buy alpha.
In fact, they would start
selling alpha. Okay?
So that's why this assumption is
so important. What would they do?
Not only with nobody by Alpha, but they
start selling it. They'd say, well,
Alpha is so expensive. Uh, you know,
let's say it's the same price as Beta.
I can sell Alpha with every elf I sell.
I can buy stock Beta.
And so I haven't done anything today,
but in the future I've got stock Beta,
which is paying me to,
I owe because I sold stock Alpha Short
I oh one. So I'll pay off the one I,
oh and I'll still be left with one.
I'm making an arbitrage profit
and so I'm not going to stop.
It's selling one share of Alpha,
also two shares of apple,
then three shares of Alpha,
then a million shares of Alpha
and everybody will be sewing, uh,
Alpha short to by Beta.
And, and uh, you know,
the market for Alpha will never clear.
So that's why the price is we'll
have to adjust. And so it can't be,
it has to be an equilibrium. And the
price of Alphas, exactly the height,
half the price of Beta,
which is to say in short,
that if you solve for this equilibrium,
you can solve for an equilibrium where,
um,
p one equals Q one is the price today
of an apple today.
And P two is the price today,
why it's called present value price
price today of an apple next year.
Hey,
so if you've got this equilibrium by,
by working your way through,
you know,
by figuring out what the price of
Alpha is. A, so the stock for example,
you want to figure out what the, what
the stock is supposed to stock of Alpha.
Suppose the price turns out to be a half,
okay.
Then by paying a half today,
you can buy stock Alpha, which is
going to pay you a whole dividend.
Okay? So the price, therefore
have an entire, oh, let's do bait.
I suppose the price of Betas
is a, is a, is a quarter. Okay.
Suppose we happened to find out
that the price of Beta is a quarter.
Then what's p two?
How much do you have to give up
today in order to get an apple? Well,
by paying a quarter today, that's
the price. By paying a quarter today,
you're getting to dividends.
So by paying a quarter today,
If you paid to get one dividend,
you'd have to pay an eighth
today. So the price, um,
p two would be an eighth
in that case. Okay? So by,
by looking piercing through
the veil of the stock market,
you can always figure out what you're
effectively paying today in order to get
an apple next period.
And that price,
which we just computed would be the same
whether we looked at it from the point
of view of going through stock Beta or
through stock alpha through a nominal
bond. And it always have
to give us the same answer.
So we know from the financial equilibrium
we can deduce what p one and p two
have to be the present value prices.
And so effectively,
furthermore,
uh, stocks the fact of late,
just add to the endowment some goods.
Okay. So, um, we can now
consider another economy.
So let's consider the economy he
hat. So the economy, the hat economy,
so you hat of x one and x two
a is the same as it was before.
You pay x one x two,
you had me of x one and x two
is the same as it was before,
but the endowments now he had a won,
he had a two.
She was going to be what?
Oh Hey.
Over here began with
one unit of each chord,
but a also own all of stock
Elfa and half we'll start Beta.
So all of stock Alpha pays
one dividend the future.
So really a effectively has claim on two
apples in the future and another half
of Beta,
which is another apple in the future.
So really a initial
endowment of goods is one.
Three. Okay. How did I get that? Again,
I said it was one apple to begin with.
He could anticipate having,
he knew he owned all the stock
Alpha. Okay. Which pays one apple.
So that's another one.
That's his and some in the future he's
going to get half of the of the dividends
or stock Beta and half of two was also
once he's got three apples in the field.
Sure. And Beta B, I'm sorry,
he had beat to,
well his one doesn't change today,
but how many, what's his claim
effectively on dividends in the future.
Okay.
One thank you. Somebody answered that. Um,
so we've now reduced the financial
equilibrium to a general equilibrium,
the same kind of economy
that we had before.
It's just that we had to
augment the endowments to
take into account that people
own stuff through the stocks.
Okay,
so what's the equilibrium of this economy?
This equilibrium has,
this has a simple general like
Librium. Okay, so what is it?
How do we solve for x?
Librium well,
take p one equal to one
and we'll solve for P two.
So let's just clear the first market.
How do you clear it?
You're with me here.
There's a standard general.
Luckily we're in the same kind
we've done many times before. So
I'll see if I can do it. So person one
is going to spend a third of his money.
And how much money does he have?
He has p one time.
So he has one plus p
two times three that's a
right, isn't dominant, is one three.
This is his income and he's spending a
third of it on good one. And the price of,
go ahead. One P one. Okay,
here it's just one and
then B is going to spend.
He's a half half Cobb.
Doug with sky.
So this is one and this is one.
He's spending half of his money in
his income is one plus p two times one
divided by one
and that has to equal the total endowment,
which is two
one plus one. So did
I go too fast? I, yes.
Well it's probably wrong. So let's see
if I, let's try it again. You have,
maybe it's two thirds. Okay, so let's
try, uh, let's see what I was, he's
doing. I'm saying here are the,
I've taken the financial economy,
which was very complicated, looks very
hard to solve and Fisher says, you know,
of course when we add
uncertainty and things like that,
we're going to have to do other tricks.
But without uncertainty,
with perfect foresight and so on,
and no one certainty, Fisher says,
this is an easy problem to solve.
You take the financial equilibrium with
all its extra variables and you realize
that people are rational.
They're going to see through
all that complicated stuff.
They're going to realize that
Alpha is just half as good as Beta.
And so they're going to
realize that by holding stock,
they're making a certain trade
off between Alpha and Beta.
And we calculated the trade off
p two was going to equal p two
p two was going to be,
what was p two I forgot what
Pete two was anyway. The the car.
How much did you have to pay?
Okay,
if you pay high alpha divided by d
alpha two something like that was p two
because by um, okay, so if,
if it costs you a certain amount
of money and you get, you know,
if it costs you a quarter, we
said, and you get a, this was bay,
so this is p two. So through either stock,
like bait is the one I solved it for.
I said,
suppose Beta,
it's also equal to Pi Alpha or ruddy
alpha two we said if the price of Beta
turns out to be a quarter and you're
getting to dividends than by paying a
quarter,
you get to dividends.
So it means to get one apple only cost
you on eighth so affect an eighth of a
dollar.
So p two we could figure out.
So once we've got our
financial equilibrium,
it basically is determining a
general equilibrium. So instead,
so let's go backwards.
Instead of solving for the financial
live in that looks complicated.
Let's solve for the general equilibrium.
What is the effect of general equilibrium?
It's the same utilities as before,
but we've augmented the
endowments according to by
looking through the veil of
the stocks. We realize that a actually
owns three apples in the future.
One because he owns all stock Alpha
and another one because he owns half of
stock Beta.
So we've got the simple economy that
we're used to solving that you did on the
first problem set so we can do it
again and solve it. So I'm going to,
I'm going to now solve
for general equilibrium.
I have to solve for p one and p two and
all the [inaudible] but I can fix one of
the prices to be one. So I'll fix p
one to be one. Then what does a do?
So I made a mistake, which is why you
weren't following me a his Cobb Douglas,
two thirds of the weight is on
good one and one third on good to,
so he's going to spend two thirds
of his money on the first God.
So that's why this should have been a two
thirds that she pointed out. Thank you.
So two thirds of his money. What's
his money's endowment is one. Three.
So it's p one times one which is one times
one plus three times p two divided by
the price. P one two thirds of the income
divide by the price of the first chord.
That's how many the first god he wants
to eat. What does she want to do?
She's going to spend,
she's patient.
She's going to spend half our income
on both goods. So half of her income,
which is one plus p two times one divided
by one. That's so many apples today.
She wants and that's what we have to
clear to clear the apple market at time
one. So it's, this makes sense now.
Yeah.
I'm looking at you in the front.
Do you,
would you agree with this
or is this confusing now?
Good. Does this make? Yep.
Okay. Someone else all, so do
you this or is this confusing?
I can say it again if it's confusing.
Yeah.
Did nominator represents what they want.
Okay. Remember how the Cobb
Douglas Work? This is the,
this is this trick I'm going to use
over and over again with log utilities.
Everybody will spend
depending on the coefficient.
So remember this utility
and the problem set,
you know that this utility is just the
same as if I put two thirds here and one
third here, right? Cause I'm just
multiplying and dividing this by three.
So instead of one and a half.
So the originally utility is this,
right?
It's a,
it's log x plus one half log x two.
So the,
some of these things is three.
The sum of this plus this is three halves.
I can multiply by two thirds.
So I've been multiply this by two thirds.
I get two thirds here and one third here,
right?
And I haven't changed
the utility function.
And now I know this is a familiar pattern.
A is always going to spend two thirds
of his money on the first short,
okay.
And B,
I could multiply this whole utility by a
half and a half and B is going to spend
and now we recognize it as
the common top dog, his thing.
And we could say that A's going to spend
half his money in the first good and
half his money on the second
court. Okay, so what have I done?
Fisher said, look, this
model is so complicated.
You're thinking in your heads
people are deciding and period one,
how much stock should I buy?
How many bonds should I buy?
How many apples should I eat?
But really if they're smart,
they're not going to think that way.
They're going to say to themselves,
how many apples should I buy today?
How many apples do I
want to consume tomorrow?
All these financial assets are just
methods for me getting apples tomorrow in
exchange for apples today.
And what's the trade off between?
The apples was the s p one and p
two is the tradeoff between apples.
You could look through
the stocks and all that,
but no matter which stock
you think of buying,
there's going to be the same trade off
between apples today and Apple's tomorrow
cause of of the no arbitrage.
You know the price of Alpha's going to
have to be exactly half the price of Beta.
So if I, once I saw for this
economy and get the price of Alpha,
I'll know how many apples today I have
to trade off in order to get apples
tomorrow.
So I might as well forget about all the
stocks and just try to figure out what
must that trade off between
p one and p two B. Okay,
so that's why you can forget about
the stocks. Forget about the bonds.
Everybody's thinking, I'm trading off
apples today for Apple's next year.
I'll make you over trades today because
I'm trading apples today in exchange for
promises for Apple's next period.
So it's as if everything happens today.
It's as if they're present
value prices today.
We trade today at prices p one and p two
for apples today and Apple's next year.
Of course the apples won't
appear till next year,
but I can sell an apple today at price p
one and by promises for apple next year
at a price p two and that's the trade off
I'm facing. If I faced that trade off,
how much of my money am I
going to spend on apples today?
I'm going to spend two thirds of my
money on apples today and the other third
I'll spend on promises for
Apple's next period. Okay,
so I mean this is a big insight
Fisher had. It's not surprising.
It's a little puzzling. I'm so used to it
that I forgotten how puzzling it is. So,
well, ask me some more questions. This was
not an obvious thought Fisher had. Yup.
Okay.
Okay. The price, often
there'll be inflation,
so Q2 the contemporaneous price
next period might be higher than the
contemporary and is priced this period.
But we don't care about that.
What we care about is how many apples
you have to give up today in order to get
apples tomorrow.
So that's called the present.
So p two is the present value price.
What do you have to give up today
to get the apple next period?
So we expect [inaudible]
to be less than p one
okay.
Precisely because what
we're going to come to that,
that's the next thing I was going to talk
about because everybody's putting more
weight on consumption today than they
are in consumption in the future.
That's why the price p one is going
to be bigger than the price Pete too.
Yup.
So we're solving for p one and P
two and present value prices. Okay?
So the crucial thing is he invented
this term, present value prices,
the prices you paid today, no matter
when you're going to get the stuff.
That's his big insight.
You should look at present value prices,
holding stocks and all that complicated
stuff is just giving you goods in the
future. So when you buy the
stocks today, you should think,
how much am I having to pay today
to get an apple in the future?
You can deduce that from the price of
stocks and how many dividends they're
paying. So everybody must have figured
out a p two what does it cost today?
How much money do I have to give up
today to get a PR an apple in the future?
Well, I have to buy a stock and then
sell the dividends and all that.
But really what I should be thinking
about is what's the price today I'm paying
for one apple in the
future and that's p two.
And so when you think about it that way,
although it's an intertemporal problem,
it looks like a new model with time.
Fisher said you can reduce it as if
they're thinking of it as if they're just
the same problem we did before with two
goods. You're trading at the same time.
That's not an obvious thing to a thought
of. No one thought of it before him. Yup.
Oh
absolutely. So this should have
been a Q two here because you,
you sell the dividend, you can get money
by selling the dividend. Thank you.
Oh Ho Ho. Very good.
Who Said who said that?
I'd have to who just asked that question?
Are you the okay,
I'll remember you. That was very
good. Exactly. So in the future,
you're getting the money for.
So what he pointed out is,
I made another mistake here in the future.
The money you're spending
on goods in the future,
you're going to get the dividends paid.
Of course you can sell the dividends
for money and the price is Q two.
So a Kutu has to appear over here,
just like there's a Q two over there.
So it's the goods times the price. That's
the money you're getting in the future.
And that's the money you're
spending on the good x too.
Yeah,
very good. Too bad you didn't ask
me that a while ago. But anyway.
Okay. Any other questions? Okay,
so we're back to this standard
general equilibrium problem.
We can take a financial equilibrium
and turn it into a general equilibrium.
And so when we solve this,
we're going to have two thirds plus p two
plus one half plus one half two equals
two. So, um,
looks like three halves. Nope,
I haven't done this wrong.
P two equals um,
to my
two thirds plus two P two. Thank
you. Yeah, I'll put two P two. Okay.
So we have to be two plus
a half plus a half be too.
So we have five halves Pete too.
That was lucky you caught
that five halves p two.
And then over here we have two minus.
Uh,
so two thirds is four six and three.
Six is nine six and 12
six minus nine six is uh,
what is this?
So what's two minus two thirds minus
a half five. Six that's correct.
Okay, so p two therefore
equals one third. All right.
So we've now solved for equilibrium.
We know that p one is gotta be one
p two has gotta be one third.
We know that,
um, we can figure out what
consumption's going to be.
I mean x a one for example,
if we wanted to solve for that,
we just plug in a third here. So we'd
have two thirds times one plus three,
which is two thirds times of four,
which is eight thirds I guess.
Okay. And you know, eggs be one we can
solve for that too. If we wanted to.
X B one is going to be a half times
four thirds, which is two thirds.
That doesn't, okay. A half plus.
What was this one third.
So it's one plus one third,
which is four thirds times a half,
which is two thirds. Is that right?
Okay.
Oh that doesn't look right.
So maybe I did this
wrong.
One plus one plus one is two.
So this is four thirds.
That looks better. Okay.
Four thirds x a one is four
thirds XP one is two thirds. Okay.
So we have four thirds and two thirds.
And so we could solve similarly for x
eight two and SB two which I won't bother
to do.
So we can figure out what the prices are,
the present value prices in the present
daily consumption. But having done that,
Fisher says, okay, we took a
hard problem. You made it easy.
Let's go back to the hard
problem. Can we? Okay.
So Fisher says the tradeoff between
good one and good to is one,
two, a third. So he defined, here's
the nominal rate of interest.
Fisher defined something called
the real rate of interest
and he said that was a variable that
you should pay a lot of attention to.
So the real rate of
interest he said is um,
p one divided by Pete too.
So this is equal to three
and so r is 200% okay,
so why did I get that?
Just as someone in the front sad,
the good too is much less expensive.
The present value of good too is much
less than the present value of good one
people.
Like people think an apple today is much
more valuable than an apple tomorrow.
So if you give up an apple today,
you can get three apples next year,
just like if you put it.
So if you put an apple in the bank,
it's like getting 200% interest on apples.
So he called it the real rate
and the apple rate of interest,
you put an apple in the bank, you know,
you give up an apple today, buy stocks,
and when it comes out in the end,
you've got 200% more apples
than you started with.
So it's the wheel rate of interest.
Okay,
so that's his crucial variable.
Now let's go back to the original
equilibrium. What is the stock price?
Assume now that cue,
assume Q one equals one. Okay.
What is the stock price? Pi Alpha.
Okay,
well we can figure it out.
How can we figure it out?
What is Pi Alpha?
Wild Stock Alpha pays one good tomorrow.
Okay,
so what is the price?
Yeah,
of five Lc.
What?
Somebody said it, I
couldn't hear it. A third.
How did I get a third?
Because we figured out that once
everybody looks through the veil,
assuming the price,
p one is one and the price Q one is one.
If they look through the veil, they're
going to say to themselves, ah Ha,
how much do I have to pay today
to get an apple in the future?
I have to pay a third to
get one apple in the future.
P One is times p two so to get one app
on the future is only a third of an apple
today.
So the stock pays one apple in the future.
So therefore,
how much do I have to pay today?
I have to pay one third of an apple today.
And since I took the
price of apples to be one,
it's going to be the price of one
third. So what's the price? Beta?
Two thirds. Okay. So Fisher said, look,
we've solved now for all
these financial things. Okay,
so
all right,
so what you can't do Fisher's theory,
Fisher's theory
does not
explain
how much,
uh,
how much of each stock,
stock, Feta, a et Cetera,
uh,
the investors hold.
Why is that? Well,
because it doesn't matter.
That's not enough is
happening in the economy yet.
Alpha and Beta are exactly the same. If
you own twice as much of the Alpha tree,
you get exactly the same
as having the Beta tree.
So how can you possibly tell whether
somebody is going to hold twice the Alpha
tree or just one Beta tree? Either
way, he's going to get the same thing.
So the theory can't possibly explain
which one they're going to do.
Somehow they'll,
they'll work it out and the divide up
the tree so that everybody ends up with
the right number of apples in the end.
And it also does not explain,
does not explain inflation.
Yeah.
Okay. Because you can't tell
what Q two is going to be.
All right, because you see in this budget
set, thanks to that inspired question.
If you double Q two Q
two appears everywhere,
you're not going to change
the second equation.
So Q two could be anything
and it uh, you're, you know,
you can double it or triple it.
It won't matter. Okay. So cute.
And the same with Q1. It's just
like vol. Ross said before,
you can always normalized prices to be
one. So the, so the theory, you know,
if he had,
he had to add another theory of money
and how many dollars were floating around
in the economy to explain Q2
this theory won't explain it.
So it does not explain inflation
and it does not explain, um,
who holds which stock.
And so it does not explain the nominal
rate of interest does not explain,
hi,
the nominal rate of interest cause $1.
Who knows what $1 is going to be worth.
It depends on how much inflation we have.
But it does explain the
real rate of interest does
explain are,
and that's the variable that Fisher sends
the one economists should always pay
attention to. The real
rate of interest. Hey, so
that's the crucial variable.
So if you want to figure out
what's the price today of a stock.
So Fisher's famous equations,
the price of a stock today.
Okay,
so Pi Alpha divided by Q one.
So the real price as somebody said,
the price and terms of gods of the
stock today is always going to equal the
dividend in the future divided
by one plus r a why is that?
That's exactly what we already used.
Okay.
This is just a rewriting
of the trick we did before.
You take the stock tomorrow and
you multiple it, so you just,
you take the dividend tomorrow,
you multiply it by p two okay.
And then you realize that one plus r is
just p one divided by p two so replacing
the p ones and p twos
by Q one and one plus R.
Today's real stock price is just
the dividends tomorrow discounted.
This is what he called
the fundamental theorem,
fundamental theorem of asset pricing.
So if you knew the real rate of interest,
you'd be able to figure out what all the
stocks were worth just by just like we
did, you know, once we knew p
one and p to the present value,
the present value prices determine the
interest rate because they're just,
as we said,
p one over p two remember it's one plus r,
so knowing p one and p two you're always
normalizing p one two B one that's the
Saint Peter's the same
as one over one plus r.
So if you know p two or
you know one of one plus R,
you know what the value of the stocks are.
That's as critical insight.
Now just to finish in third yes,
Q one
he won,
which is the same as p one you know,
because it's today's price in both
the contemporaneous price today is the
present value of price today.
Okay,
so let me just end on this
one. Node Fisher said, okay,
we can take financial
equilibrium without uncertainty,
reduce it to channel equilibrium. We know
everything about general equilibrium.
Therefore,
we know everything about
financial equilibrium and
we realized that the crucial
variable in general
equilibrium is relative prices.
There is no just interest rate. The
nominal interest rate. Who the hell cares?
The real interest rate is what we care
about and just be calm. And Justin,
normal economics,
there's no just relative price.
There's no just real interest rate.
It depends on people's utilities.
You make the more patient and the,
you know,
and that's going to affect the real
interest rate and make them less patient.
It's going to affect the real industry.
You'll give them more endowments
today versus tomorrow.
That's going to affect
the real interest rate,
the relative price between
today and tomorrow.
That's the way you should
think about finance.
That's the way you should explain what's
going on in the financial markets.
So in the problem set, you're just
going to do a problem like that.
And then I'm going to give more
interpretations of this that Fisher gave.
So I guess I'm out of time.
So I'll just stop here.